Speaker 1: You know, there's this movement on
the right that claims to be for law and order.
They say investigate or let law enforcement do
its thing back. The blue law enforcement is good.
Allow them. Don't obstruct them. Don't tamper
with witnesses. Rand Paul, the Republican senator
from Kentucky, upon learning that Donald Trump
is under investigation for possible violations
of the Espionage Act, says, Oh, well, we got to
get rid of that Espionage Act. That's the problem
is the law. Rand Paul calls for a repeal
of Espionage Act amid DOJ investigation
into Trump taking classified documents to Mar
a Lago. Look at this tweet from Rand Paul.
Quote, The Espionage Act was abused from the
beginning to jail dissent. Years of World War One.
It is long past time to repeal this
egregious affront to the First Amendment.
Repeal the Espionage Act. The Future of Freedom
Foundation. You know, if this has been a problem,
Rand, since World War One, you've had a long time,
like 100 years during which you could have lobbied
for its repeal. And it just so happens that
he only comes out and talks about it publicly.
Days after we learn hours, in fact, after we
learn that one of the possible crimes that Trump
committed is a violation of that very espionage
act. Rand Paul could have been like I don't know
how old he has got to be, about 50 something. Rand
Paul could have been talking about the Espionage
Act for a very long time during his time as
senator. When did he become elected? When was Rand
Paul elected senator? 2010. No. 2016. Anyway, I'm
not sure. Sometime in the 20 tens. Rand Paul for
over a decade could have been saying we must get
rid of this Espionage Act. But it's within hours
of the leaked document indicating Trump is
being suspected of violating the Espionage
Act. Then he comes out against it. Now, it's
not always the case that Rand Paul was so soft
on crime. You know, Republicans claim that they
are very tough on crime and they say we have laws
and we must abide by the laws. That's what
it is. And sometimes we on the left say,
well, you know, some laws are unjust, some
laws are unfair. And they say, no, no, no,
you must abide by the law. He wasn't
always soft on crime. Here's Rand
Paul in Sept 2017 with a very different
perspective when it comes to intelligence
and documents and leaks. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Susan Rice unmasked anybody. We
should have a record of it, but it goes beyond
even the top echelon. You know, we had an NSA
security analyst, a low level analyst recently
caught revealing documents. And we just can't
have everybody in the intelligence community.
They they have such power to suck up every bit
of every transmission, every communication we
ever made. We can't just have them willy nilly
releasing that to the public. So General Flynn's
conversation was released that may not have been
up in Susan Rice. She may have unmasked him, but
it may well have been analysts down lower. All of
them have to be found. And I guarantee you there's
a paper or a computer trail of who released these
documents and who release these conversations.
Speaker 1: Wow. Wow. He used to say that
if you're handling publicizing, releasing,
leaking, moving any irresponsible actions
with classified documents, the individuals doing
that have to be held accountable and every single
one of them should be found. Now it's Trump and
he says, repeal the Espionage Act. These people
are pathetic. And you know, the theme, there's no
principles. It's what's convenient at the time.
Then the subject matter was not convenient.
So Rand Paul said, find the leakers,
prosecute the leakers, all everybody
being irresponsible with these documents,
anybody who moved the document to a place it
wasn't supposed to be. Get all of them. Now
it's his buddy Trump who's doing it and it's no
longer convenient. And so now it's repeal the law
under which he would potentially be
charged. These people are pathetic.